so just as a as a sub point whenever
you're learning something new
you should always connect it to what you
already know which is why we're going to
review a little bit okay so what we're
gonna do is um try and match up if your
member thank you
we're gonna try to match up some
equations and rules that was the algebra
stuff right so I might even write that
down equations with what's this topic
called we have our stuff with the G no
quiet we are doing some geography but
it's grass but we're gonna graphs right
so you may remember I gave you a
metaphor for this write the equations
and Rawls they're all written in algebra
okay so here's an example we'll do this
one very quickly they're all written in
algebra okay but then you have what they
look like right so it's kind of feel for
something visually so that we said you
know getting the senses involved so this
is what this particular one looks like
right so the metaphor I gave you was
it's a bit like reading sheet music just
marks on page right versus hearing the
thing C okay so this is where we started
this is our basic linear graph okay
let's think of it what happens if we
change this just a little just a little
what if we take this I just stick a 1 on
the n plus 1 what would be the
difference hmm I'll give you a bit of a
clue I'll give you a bit of a clue in
this case here this is really a plus 0
but I mean we don't usually write plus 0
cuz ya do your own nothing changes right
but therefore these are these numbers
here that's that's what's been slightly
adjusted so what effect is I have yeah
very good
that's exactly right sir here
the y-intercept is 0 there he is in fact
I should probably and you should
probably write that number in 0 for y
but here it's a plus one so it's not
there it's up a little bit okay so
that's changed what's the same yeah well
it's the gradient very good
the gradient is the number in front of
the X and the special fancy name for
that is the coefficient right the number
in front of the X don't worry about that
word coefficient it's both one okay both
one okay there's a one there or one day
they verify to you okay so therefore
these lines when we draw them they ought
to be parallel to each other like so so
this is y equals x this is y equals x
plus one has been moved up one unit okay
now just one more example and I'll just
be able to fit it on here if instead of
adding a number here what if we multiply
by something so if I said like y equals
2x okay
well it would be the difference now
between this one and this one it's up
the middle okay you can see just like in
the first case it's still up plus zero
hanging over onion so the y intercept
will be zero very good okay so that's
the sync so I'm still passing through
the origin just like I am there so I'll
just okay but what's different what's
different what effect is that to have
what do you think suppose you've been
watching what do you reckon
cinema gets a view that that's that's
exactly right
um this to write versus the the one
that's hiding doing it right what it
means is that the gradient is a bigger
number one to two which makes it steeper
that's exactly right so let's try and
draw this kind accurately right so see
how these guys are parallel well this
one won't be parallel because he's
steeper so let's draw it up like this
okay
very good so we started with this y
equals x that was our simple thing we
saw what happened when we added a number
we saw what happened when we multiplied
by a number but what if so this is now
where we're going into new territory
okay what will happen if we try
something different okay so instead of
adding a number or multiplying by a
number I'm gonna multiply by another X
has been confusing x times X now not
only is that confusing Islam we know
better language to write this in nice
concise I want to call this you know
there's two of them right so it's really
x squared that's a much more concise way
to write it
that's x times X okay so what would this
thing look like well we're going to
appeal back to the tool that we used
before it's a bit of a blunt instrument
but if we do it all together it'll be
pretty quick right which is to draw up a
table of values you can know nothing
about what this thing's meant to do but
if we can punch in some values we'll see
what's going on so draw your self one
with a few columns on it right we're
gonna try some X values and then we'll
see what happens to the Y values all
right now we usually do kind of like
zero one and two and then we see what
happens with
that's that's usually a put enough set
of values but for reasons that would
come clear in a second I'm going to try
a few other valleys as well yeah I'm
going to go off to the left okay cuz
we've got that here right you've got a
bit to the right left right so we can do
exactly the same thing here let's start
with the easy numbers if X is equal to
zero right then Y will be equal to 0
square what see her square it's still 0
very good so there you go I've got value
let's keep this kid going this way if X
is equal to 1 what will Y be will be 1
squared which is 1 1 squared not 1 plus
1 okay now we get to the 2 now if X is
equal to 2 oh good I can use slightly
get the pan now I haven't put it on
there but just suppose what if I kept
going if it's 3 what would you expect
next 9 9 good and it moves for these
names
yeah I can't you getting it so good you
you'll keep those numbers in your head
let's start the rest of the table that's
good let's go this way if actually could
you negative 1 so when I square it I'm
gonna write this down just to be sure
when X is equal to negative 1 Y is equal
to now be super careful I'm gonna put
brackets just to make it really obvious
right there's my negative 1 and I'm
going to square it okay makes a
difference if you have brackets here
right because this is minus 1 times
minus 1 and what happens when you've got
two negatives they cancel right they
become plus
well that's okay you don't need to be
afraid for the next one because you
probably see what's gonna happen if I
now put in negative two instead hold on
you're still gonna add two negatives
right it'll be negative two times
negative two
again the negatives cancel so whatever
can you get well done good so hold on
this is a bit weird you know you know in
like words right words like say um looks
like say racecar racecar is a cool word
because yeah yeah it's if you if you say
it backwards if you write out the
letters backward so you get the same
words we have names that he's write to
me what they call start with the P
palindromic that's right this is a
palindrome it's the same one way as it
is the other in your game you're getting
the same thing yeah okay yes no
unfortunately not just like just like
the word German is not German because
it'd be Jewish whatever you know Germany
is not German maybe Deutschland back
anyway